you were what
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
so Bitcoin huh the significance of
Bitcoin and what it represents is
different depending on who you ask some
see it as a currency others see it as an
asset class to invest in and others
still view it as a wealth transfer from
the old monetary system to the new
monetary system legally it's not even
clear to regulators what Bitcoin should
be classed as despite this there's been
a huge mania around the cryptographic
currency recently so what is it
roughly speaking Bitcoin is a new form
of secure currency that doesn't need a
bank government agency or only middleman
to operate the people within the system
just carry out transactions among
themselves in what's called a
decentralized network or blockchain if
you want to know more about the inner
workings of Bitcoin I have a finance
playlist where I talk to some experts in
their respective fields in the video
titled Bitcoin versus normal currency
things are about to change
I talked about how Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies work and how there are
reaction to the mismanagement of central
banking and the debt based economic
system I recommend watching those for
some background knowledge before
continuing with this video also a
shout-out to those who messaged me
saying they watched those videos and
have made a small fortune since I
enjoyed hearing his stories today it's
just going to be a fun little video
about the size and rapid growth of
Bitcoin one of the fastest growing
assets in all of history
firstly how many bitcoins are there
there will only ever be 21 million
bitcoins in existence currently 16
million of those 21 million coins have
been given out into circulation when
bitcoins market crossed 100 billion
dollars in October of 2017 it had a
market value larger than Goldman Sachs
Morgan Stanley bhp and Netflix bitcoins
market cap today is over 300 billion
dollars at the time of writing and it's
currently around seventeen thousand
dollars a coin there's no way of knowing
where it's gonna be by the time you
watch this but we'll just go with those
numbers for now here's a chart from
MarketWatch
putting Bitcoin into perspective right
now it's about 40% the size of Apple and
72% the size of Amazon but Bitcoin
doesn't compare to gold at only about 3%
of that asset or the value of the total
US dollars in circulation bitcoins
current market cap is bigger than the
GDP of Ireland and Pakistan and the
energy consumption to mine bitcoins
globally is more than all of these
countries it takes a staggering 14,000
kilowatt hours to mine one Bitcoin since
its start in 2009 Bitcoin is the sixth
most circulated currency in the world
it's estimated that about fourteen
million people around the world hold
Bitcoin there are 13 million users on
coinbase the biggest Bitcoin exchange
and they've tripled their users since
the start of the year in fact at some
points during December coinbase was
signing up 200,000 people per day the
Winklevoss twins yes the very same ones
who claimed that Mark Zuckerberg stole
their idea for Facebook are now the
first Bitcoin billionaires they bought
11 million dollars of coins in 2013 at
around 260 dollars per coin
in December of 2017 bitcoin was launched
in the futures market bursting it
straight into the mainstream financial
world the cryptocurrency started trading
futures last night on the CBOE
it has been a wild ride opening with a
thousand-dollar spike 1000 contracts
trading hands in the first hours
I think banking institutions are going
to take advantage of this they're gonna
try and smash Bitcoin in their favor
I really wouldn't be surprised if they
get on the phone with their buddies push
up the price and then when they're
getting ready to dump they'll let their
friends know and make bets ahead of time
to make a huge profit this is obviously
just my opinion and just a hunch but I
think it's quite likely central banks
are also taking note the Federal Reserve
just did a paper about Bitcoin and the
blockchain and they're researching into
their own closed version the Reserve
Bank of Australia is also talking about
their own form of cryptographic currency
so it's a Bitcoin a bubble I personally
think most probably to see why it's
worth looking at how the Bitcoin user
base has changed over time the early
adopters came in four categories the
first group were just geeks they thought
the idea of using a computer to generate
currency was a neat idea back in 2010 a
home computer could make a decent amount
of Bitcoin at five cents a coin the
second group for anarcho-capitalists
usually anti-government these guys love
the idea of decentralized and pseudo
anonymous currency that was completely
outside the debt-based central banking
system another group of criminals
these guys also like the anonymous
nature and would spend Bitcoin on sites
like Silk Road to obtain illegal items
like firearms and drugs the final group
for libertarians who appreciated the
idea of a limited amount of Bitcoin as
opposed to the central banking method
which could print as much money as they
liked when they felt like it the
libertarians didn't like central bank's
and looked at old fiat currency with a
sense of suspicion these four groups
were enough to get the ball rolling on
Bitcoin and in those early years the
price was more or less stable as time
went on the price gradually began to
increase for various reasons and people
and the news media began to take notice
then that brings us to today where a lot
of the mainstream adopters don't really
understand what bitcoin is all about
usually it goes that they've heard about
it on the news and they just hear about
people making money and see the price
going up and they want in on the action
people are seeing this growth and it's
just it's it's changing everything it's
a natural human instinct but it also it
can be classified as speculation and
massive amounts of speculation are one
of the hallmarks of a bubble but on the
other hand Bitcoin is a little different
currently Bitcoin is less than 0.1% the
value invested in all other major assets
this technically means that there's a
lot of room to grow it's also easier to
get into Bitcoin than stock trading so
this bubble could go for longer than
most people might expect I ultimately
think that bitcoin is not going to be
the cryptocurrency to lead them all
another cryptocurrency is going to come
along that has a better technical
performance that will probably knock
Bitcoin off its throne in the years to
come
but anyway that's just me thinking out
loud and I think this whole thing is
very interesting another worry is the
deflationary spending problem because
the price of Bitcoin keeps rising people
are going to hoard it and treat it like
a form of digital gold instead of
currency this will the means of
exchange aspect of Bitcoin until the
price stabilizes all no it's pretty
insane how one Klain was just five cents
in 2011 and that became worth $800 at
the beginning of 2017 and $17,000 near
the end of 2017
it is pretty remarkable so anyway that's
it so that's a bit about the size of
Bitcoin and some other interesting
aspects about it I hope you learned
something from this video so thanks for
watching this has been - go go you've
been watching cold fusion feel free to
subscribe to this channel if you've just
stumbled across it and I'll see you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]